who takes home the pizza award let me
just get one more smell before i decide
okay
i have the meat sweats
[Music]
so
when it comes to pizza give me the words
to me there's nothing better than a
slice loaded up with all my favorite
toppings meat lovers pizza has long
represented peak excess on a pie but
today i'll be creating the ultimate
carnivores feast by using the uuni koda
16 to roast some high end cuts of beef
for my pizza
my challenger today is chef esther troy
from mukbar in new york city s detroit
is a master when it comes to meat heavy
korean comfort cooking and is always on
the lookout for ways to level up a
classic dish
and of course we have the perfect judge
for this event
eric wareheim made his name as one half
of the comedy duo tim and eric but his
new cookbook food heim proves that this
guy has a serious appetite
can esther and i reimagine a meat
lover's pizza crazy enough to impress
eric there's only one way to find out
esther i'm so glad you're here it's
gonna be a ton of fun welcome to pete's
awards thank you for having me it's such
an honor to be here and let me just say
i've been watching the show and i love
you love the pizza and you win a lot not
really
not as much as i should
so today is all about meat lovers pizza
what do you think is the appeal of a
meat lover's pizza is it decadence is
there a time and place what do you think
normally what i crave is like a pure
pizza like i just like plain cheese i'm
a new yorker i like my new york slice
but sometimes you know you want variety
a meat lover's pizza it's literally that
it's like if you love meat and you want
something salty and if you're like
hungover maybe this is the pizza you
want sounds amazing i can't wait so what
do you got going on over there this
pizza i'm calling it army pizza so
there's this traditional stew in korea
called army stew oh and it's basically
your quintessential korean-american dish
so when the american troops came over to
korea during the war they brought over
like canned meats right preserved meats
and then koreans would take that and
then mix it with kimchi and make a stew
so that's kind of like the history
behind army stew and i felt like why
don't i make that a pizza that sounds
amazing
let's go first of all i have a dough
that's kind of like your new york style
so this sauce is really special it's a
kimchi tomato sauce so next step spam i
ground the spam up because i know that
people can be a little bit weird about
spam so i'm kind of like disguising it
and making it kind of into a sausage and
of course bacon oh because we need that
smokiness and then um kimchi kimchi
which i know that you love and then pork
belly oh so this is pork belly that's
been are you talking to me it's been
cured and then braised for five hours
and then chilled and then sliced it and
i put two types of cheese on my meat
lovers
american cheese slice is a must okay
so i was like i gotta put that in the
middle okay right and then of course
mozzarella because you know it's pizza
and then i have these mini curab
sausages oh wait
yeah right and these japanese sausages
it comes from like berkshire pork so
it's super good it's very smoky okay and
i sliced it like in coins so it acts as
like kind of like the rhony so
pizza's ready looks great gonna throw it
in the oven all right
looking good
all right it's ready i'm gonna pull it i
can't wait to get a slide
looks so good
and now of course we have to finish it
okay so chili oil
my favorite chili oil and pizza right
like genius so and then i have some
watercress
for me even if it's a meat lover's pie
balance in any type of food you're
making is important
so excited for you to try this nicole
you don't understand when i first made
this i ate the entire pie
in that setting like i couldn't stop
eating it i might eat the entire pie
oh wait she's showing off she's showing
off structure it looks good right it
looks it's kind of perfect
mmm
the sauce i love a juicy pie
it's like you it's like oozy juicy nice
it actually feels very comforting i feel
like you hugged me you hugged me with
your pizza i hugged you
i love it
the bake is incredible i love a juicy
pizza i love chili oil so this is a win
for me to me everything turned out how i
wanted it crispy
leopard spotting
good structure in the dough and like you
said comfort food that's what i do
and uh yeah i'm really happy with this
esther are you ready to see what i'm
cooking up over here born ready
my family's from jamaica so i'm so
excited today to be making
my version of oxtail and cocoa bread but
pizza i freaking love that that's my
inspiration i made a cocoa bread kind of
crust so it's like coconut milk based
and then i added like some nutmeg all
spices a little touch of cinnamon so
first i'm going to put my sauce
so this is just a simple tomato you know
because i have so many flavors today i
tried not to over season my marinade
okay i have three kind of cheese today i
have oaxaca because i needed a little
extra flavor
i have like grande the traditional low
moisture right and then i have gruyere
and this is going to go so well with me
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
put some roasted red peppers down i had
some mushrooms right but i rolled it
around in an oxtail gravy you know no
football double okay we're doing this
right
so we have our wonderful uni right here
nice and hot
i'm gonna launch this pie my onion set
to like 700 degrees not too hot not too
cold like right in the middle and then
when it comes out i'm gonna put some
oxtail on here okay ready all right
let's do this thing
and there we are voila
beautiful shut up
something great all right so now
everything we've been waiting for yes
the oxtail moment so this is a lot of me
to put on a pizza but the challenge is
meat lovers yes i'm gonna add everyone's
favorite some good old bacon
and then this is the part
where
i got a little crazy
i got some chit chat on and i'm just
gonna squeeze this chicharron you want
to squeeze some with me um i'm just
gonna squeeze this chicharron all over
the pizza
i like squeezing
the texture
yes
okay and then to that i'm going to add
some spring onion
and then i'm going to just give a little
chicharron for the center
and
a flower
so there you have it i love it the
oxtail meat lovers pizza
what do you think it's beautiful ready
to try it oh my gosh i've been dying for
this okay yeah this is a two-hander oh
we have a little cheese pool this is
what i like in pizza yeah me too
cheers
enjoy oh
so nicole i'm so impressed thank you
coming from you that means everything
the dough is nice and soft but still a
little chewy i get the essence of the
coconut milk which is awesome but really
the money is the oxtail
super succulent soft
i've got a winner esther we had two meat
packed pizzas today but now we got to go
to the judges table we have eric werheim
as the judge today he's a comedian he's
a cookbook author and he's also a piece
of purist so let's see if we can win him
over today we got this girl i think we
do
hi i'm eric werheim international pizza
expert and i'm this week's judge on
pizza wars and i don't take no
bribes this is real
a lot of beeps on
the most important thing about pizza to
me is balance i consider pizza to be
like sushi or wine it's got to have the
right amount
of acid in your sauce the right amount
of
fat in the cheese and that's harmony i'm
a meat man i love all kinds of meat i
like barbecue i like steaks but meat on
my pizza meat lovers pizza i'm a little
skeptical
[Music]
all right pizza number one
at first glance it's gorgeous it doesn't
look over stuffed it looks really
balanced
wow
this thing is a monster let's give it a
try
first of all the dough is beautiful
there's a little kind of maybe semolina
on the bottom is good bake
i really love the greens on top the
watercress a little refreshing palette
cleanser to all this meat
my only real note on this is the amount
of cheese but i would say you hold back
maybe 10 of the cheese this would be a
perfect pizza
i love korean food
i love pizza pie this is gonna get a
high score
[Music]
all right my second pizza
has arrived uh this one looks beautiful
as well as an oxtail pizza i'm scared
and excited at the same time
let's take a bite pillowy soft crust i'm
just gonna go for a bite of that first
because i'm
into it
beautiful
look at this thing
look at this sucker it's loaded to the
mount with meats
looks like there's a thousand meats in
here
what's also really interesting there's
mushrooms in here but mushrooms kind of
taste like meat it cooked properly and i
thought it felt it was like a pork belly
so it kind of just really
works it's a nice little trickerini this
is a meat lovers challenge and
i would say this
is a 10 out of 10 in terms of
meatness we got oxtail we got bacon we
got mushrooms that kind of tastes like
meat we got chicharrones
my one note here is the amount of
toppings look at this
i can barely pick this up i need two
hands i actually need three hands to
hold this pie this has been amazing we
had two beautiful
meaty pies
it's gonna be hard to choose a winner
i'm gonna go take a nap for about eight
hours i'm gonna wake up
stretch
meditate
and then crown a winner
eric we're so excited to have you here
today
esther and i we like
worked our asses off
and thank you for being here it's an
honor
to be here as you know i am top meat man
internationally known recognized
and this was a hard one the korean army
pizza i respect it it's beautiful i love
it the watercress gives you that little
pop the american cheese
never had that before wild usually put
that on my burgers but i liked it on my
pie now we go to the oxtail pizza just
look at this masterpiece look at this
cornichon
it's huge it's fluffy there is enough
meat on here
to feed all of brooklyn i would say this
is a tough challenge
i
took a nap for about eight hours
tried to decide
what is the best meat lover's pizza and
i still don't know so i'm gonna go take
another nap
eric no more naps okay no more naps we
are dying to know
who takes home the meat lovers challenge
pizza award let me just get one more
smell before i decide okay
i have the meat
[Laughter]
i'm sweats to take like a 30 second
knock can i take a 30 second now okay no
more naps
the winner is
oxtail
[Applause]
oh my
great job i love you so much i went with
the oxtail as our grand champion because
just look at this look at the amount of
meat on this i've never seen anything
like this
i was turned on by it i was scared of it
i had so many emotions going into this
pizza it's just a meat masterpiece thank
you that means the world to me thank you
so much esther you were phenomenal i
hope i get to cook with you again thank
you eric and we'll see you next time on
peace awards
[Music]
shhh